why not because you got guns out that's
that's my choice i'm not going to move
my hand from my steering wheel
that you guys were waiting you celebrity
you know who i am i'm offset from amigos
that's why they following me bro offset
had a confrontation with the police on
saturday
while he was on instagram live you just
watched somebody beat my car up with a
flag
what are you talking about you told me
put my hands up i'm not doing that you
put my hands up it's 25 000 people in my
life i'm telling you you're gonna get
sued
e.t has learned that the rapper was not
arrested but he was detained
by police officers in a statement to e.t
offset's rep said that he was detained
by the beverly hills police department
following a quote attack by aggressive
trump supporters
and he was released shortly after we
bless you dude
that's it his rep went on to say that
the migos rapper quote
thanks his fans for their support and
wishes everyone peace
and safety during these trying times
my kids gotta have money not just me
they're selfish
oh i take the crowd off the king like
mike
the beverly hills police later released
a statement
regarding the incident confirming that
offset was not
arrested however cardi b's cousin who he
was with
marcelo armanza was arrested for
carrying a concealed weapon
and carrying a loaded firearm in public
look how many speakers i'm scared now
we're going to get jumped
i really feel like we're going to get
jumped prior to offset's detainment
cardi who had been hanging out with her
husband the night before
shared a video of herself driving
through l.a
drum supporters are everywhere i'm
scared
i don't like it with a big truck
i don't like this dude look at this look
at this look how they're walking around